The prophet Muhammad sallallah.aihi
wasallam told us that whoever builds a
mosque for Allah, Allah will build for
him a sim at a house in Jenna. And we
know the great reward that will not only
be gained but rather will fill your
grave after your death. Whenever someone
prays there, whenever someone gives
shahada in the masid, whenever someone
learns something in the masid, yes, that
will be something that you'll have on
your scale.
[Music]
How are you guys doing? Alhamdulillah.
We're doing good. You're doing good,
huh? Alhamdulillah. Well, you've been
unbanned from India now, haven't you? Is
that good news or bad news? I don't
know. It must be bad news. It must be
bad news for the enemies, for the ops.
It means we're not much of a threat
anymore. But let's find out first. Let's
see if it's true that we've been banned,
unbanned I should say from India on
YouTube, on Twitter, let us know. If
you're in India and you're and you're
not watching us from VPN and just let us
know because we we were both banned by
directly from the government. Yeah. You
know, because of our whatever it is
activism, anti-Indian government
activism and we did miss our viewers,
the Indian viewers that alhamdulillah
are very active and they Yeah, we miss
them man. Yeah, we miss them. And uh
talking about uh important Asians who
have making uh strides. Yeah. Political
strides. You got another Indian. His
name is uh Zahan Mamani. He is he Indian
or from Uganda. So his parents are
originally from India. I think one of
them is from Gujarat and the other one I
think they migrated to Uganda or
something but Indian origins. Yeah.
Sure. So I mean some people have been
speaking about him as an individual
who's been voted as a a mayor in New
York similar to Sadi Khan here in
London. Um he's got the same kind of
views. He's probably I would call him a
liberal liberal secularist socialist in
his case. He has the same exact views on
LGBT, the same exact views on
transgender rights and all these kind of
things. And there's nothing about him in
political life anyway which indicates
any semblance of Islamic identification.
Of course, he identifies as a Muslim,
but that's aside the point. Now, there's
been, I would say, two extremes on how
this Tell me what you think of this. I
mean, bounce ideas back and forth, me
and you. But, you know, there's two
extremes, I think, on how to deal with
his case. There's one extreme which
basically throws the baby out with the
bath water. M it's clear that he despite
his non um allegiance to traditionalist
values or his views which are
incommensurate or in congruent with uh
traditionalist Sunni or Shia by the way
because he identifies as to Shia but
traditionalist views from either of
those perspectives despise in congruence
with that he's definitely better than
his alternative which is you know a
Zionist or supporter of Israel etc. So
from that perspective, for the pro
Palestinian cause, he's definitely good.
And that's why you'll find people on the
right-wing far right attacking him.
Yeah. And defaming him and talking about
him eating food from the with his hands
and so on and you know what I mean? Like
as if you know. And we saw the likes of
Joe Rogan reacting to a clip of his
where he was on stage with his uh the
people that he was competing with and
they were all asked one question which
was where would you go after you know
your election and all of them
unanimously said Israel when the camera
panned to Zahan he said I'd I'd stay
here and for Joe Rogan and a lot of
people that was like that was a game
changer and a lot of people were saying
Why is somebody that's being elected for
New York being asked about Israel?
Steven Coar, that was the first question
he asked him. Does Israel have a right
to exist? So, that definitely was um a
significant part of his running for a
mayor as well and why a lot of people I
think this whole pro Palestinian notion
is becoming more acceptable in the
higher kind of echelons the more Israel
continues its genocide. Absolutely. And
it is significant for the pro
Palestinian cause that you have somebody
who is unabashedly pro Palestine whether
they're Muslim or non-Muslim by the way
and we'll come to this point in a second
but you know that has been elected with
a majority which is a significant
majority 56% of the vote I think he got
and about 570,000
uh votes and in the biggest city in the
United States which is New York City. So
that is significant and it does show
that there if anything there has been a
shift in public opinion even more
probably than anticipated because his
brand the reason why he answered that
way is because his brand is a pro
Palestinian brand and that is probably
one of the reasons why he was even
elected because it's probably
underestimated how many people actually
despise the the policies of Israel at
this point in time and the genocide that
they're doing and so on. So I think that
is something worth speaking about. Would
you add any point to that? I think a
thing that really bugged these people
especially the rightwing they were
saying that New York hosts the biggest
population of Jews than any other city
other than of course the the illegal
state of Israel. So that was something
that really kind of bugged them and
that's why they were really emphasizing
on this connection with with Israel to
such a degree that somebody was on air
saying you know what they should seeen
as the there are a lot of Jews there
people should go to Israel but would
that would you then apply that to other
cities what about there are majority
Muslim cities that does that mean they
have to go to Makkah Medina does that
does that mean they have to go to you
know Muslim majority country. I mean,
where's that link? But there's a very
unhealthy
uh link fixation. Yeah. Fixation of
especially the UK and the US that we're
seeing with Israel. I mean, the pull
that they have, the the colonization of
the minds and the politics and the
economy is actually very very
disturbing. Disturbing. Yeah. So, that's
one thing. I mean, the other extreme, so
we said there are two extremes on how to
deal with a case like Mr. Mlani over
here. M one of them is to to throw the
baby out with the bath water and to say
well it doesn't matter you know if he's
pro Palestinian or not he is pro-LGBT he
doesn't have our views in terms of
transgenderism and so on and so forth
and therefore you know we have to throw
him out okay look even if it was a
non-Muslim all right Bernie Sanders
Jeremy Corbin someone like that um who
is pro Palestine and you got a chance
that there could be some level of change
even if it's a 1% change in public
opinion in whatever it may be social,
political, economic,
um that helps our brothers and sisters
in Palestine, then that is a good thing.
Okay, from that perspective, it's a good
thing. However, to link him with Islam
overtly or any other way, I think is
disingenuous. He doesn't even link
himself with Islam when it comes to
politics. He's not actually used Islam
in any way, shape or form to to shape or
form his. So it's disingenuous on on the
side of the right-wing who are
portraying him as an Islamist. I don't
know what Islamist is pro-LGBT. What
Islamist is protransgenders. Right. This
is actually it shows ignorance. It shows
illiteracy. Academic, social, religious,
and political illiteracy. Someone made a
good point. They said he's not a Muslim
running for office. He is somebody that
secular liberal uh secular liberal uh
that happens to be a Muslim that's been
elected as mayor. Well, that's the
thing. I mean, some people would even
question that frankly because, you know,
I don't see how it's possible for a
person to claim to be a Muslim on the
one hand and have these beliefs which
are antithetical to what is referred to
as
something known for the religion by
necessity. Now obviously him being and
this is going to sound controversial but
I mean let's just say anyways him being
a 12 Shi I'm not saying all 12 of Shiais
believe in this but there there are
interpretations of Shiism which allow
you to perform which is to lie about
your religion now this is not found in
Sunni Islam okay you you'll find that
lying is restricted to two or three uh
scenarios like wars etc etc in Sunni
Islam but in Shia Islam it's way more
broad under some interpretations
And so because of that, one could argue
maybe he's just lying, you know, about
his religion or this that and the other
in order to save himself from political
life, this that and the other. So that
he's got more wheel than someone like,
for example, Hamza Yusf, the one who was
the Scottish prime minister for a while.
Nevertheless, I I think to be honest,
you know, him calling himself a Muslim
wouldn't suffice us to have him as some
kind of a representative for us. For me,
he is the same as a Bernie Sanders. In
fact, I'll be honest. I'll be totally
honest with you, right? If it was a
matter of I know Bernie Sanders is not
running for may mayor in in New York,
but let's for the sake of argument
someone with the same views as Bernie
Sanders being a white man and a liberal
and a socialist for example or prog or
whatever it may be. I would rather like
if it was a it was a choice between
Mandani and Bernie Sanders, Bernie
Sanders would be the lesser of two evils
because there's no confusion. M there's
no confusion that you know you're trying
to mix you know your religious identity
which is antithetical to these notions
these sexual notions or these gender
identity notions. I would rather have a
white man or a white woman in fact yeah
representing our interests than a brown
man eating with his to be honest with
his hands but then causing all this
anger and backlash okay from the far
right and then having people mix and
compromise their religion in this way.
Do you know if if I had to choose
between Bernie Sanders and Mamani, I'd
choose Bernie Sand. If I had my own
choice, I'd choose Bernie Sanders for
those reason. There's a clear
demarcation when it comes to a person's
belief. Whilst here, it raises a lot of
questions. People would be like, "Okay,
so he's Muslim, but he's doing this, but
but he's from here. He looks like us."
Yeah. So, Islam should not be used. And
this is a criticism that has to be
leveled. Okay. It should Islam and
Muslim identity should not be used for
political leveraging. Okay. It's why are
you bringing into the equation that
you're a Muslim when you support all
these things which are non-Islamic? But
was that part of his campaigns or Yeah,
it's a big part of his identity
politics, right? I am this and I'm that
Muslim and whatever. Surely that comes
up though, right? It does. But I'm
saying that, you know, if if you want to
just be a brown man who's a liberal
socialist, maybe if someone asks you
here and there, yes, I have, you know,
Muslim background or something like that
or culture, but to make it somewhat of,
okay, this is what I am, I'm eating. I
think there is something to be said
about, okay, this is a bit, we're not
going to as a Muslim community, as a
traditionalist Muslim community, we
can't fall for this. What what I think
we've brushed over as well is the fact
that he identifies as a socialist.
Yeah, this doesn't necessarily make
sense. On the one hand, you're saying
Allah has created everything and all of
the systems and we believe in objective
morality. On the other hand, we say when
it comes to economics and when it comes,
let's go to KM maybe. Yeah. We'll go to
this uh non-Muslim.
Yeah. That's come up with his own system
and that's where Allah and his system,
you know, didn't reach and it doesn't
suffice for us. So, that in itself
doesn't make sense and we shouldn't we
shouldn't normalize that. And so, that
these are the two extremes. I mean I
heard Yasar Khadi with all my love and
respect to him you know but saying
calling this a civilizational victory.
Oh you're calling his his you know being
elected a civilizational victory. In
what sense that this is the question is
it a victory for the Palestinian cause.
If you had put it in that language look
this is a this is a good thing for the
Palestinian cause. I think that would be
non-controversial calling it a
civilizational victory is it what kind
what civilization are we talking about?
The Islamic civilization. So the
socialist civilization this is why I
don't understand LGBT civilization.
There are two extremes here bro and like
you know pragmatism has its limitations.
Islamic Sharia consequentialism has its
limitations you know um and its limits
are Islamic Sharia consequentialism's
limits are the red lines of
or what is known in the religion by
necessity. That's what it's limited by.
And so, you know, with this person being
elected and, you know, them attacking
him, the right-wing, it actually shows
how true Allah's words are when he said
that the Jews and the Christians will
not be happy with you until you follow
their way. And here is a liberal
socialist individual that promotes LGBT
rights and, you know, does whatever he
does, but it's still not enough. He's
seen eating with his hands and you've
got people smashing him for that, saying
he has no place in Western civilized
society. You've got Donald Trump
smashing him. Laura Luma, who's an
individual that was caught on camera
eating dog food with her hands, she's
saying that this is unacceptable and
this is wrong. Another guy who's married
to a woman. So, this is a congressman
whose father-in-law eats with his hands.
These guys eat burgers and chips with
their hands. And Jesus, apparently,
according to them, he used to eat with a
fork and knife. No, he used to eat with
his hands. Yeah, it's a good point. How
did you How did Jesus eat? That's that's
a great question. But now the point is
that despite him bending over backwards
for them like Sadi Khan as well, when it
comes to LGBT and all of this, it's
still not enough for these people. It's
just not enough. That's why we can't
There's two things. Yes, we accept that
you're pro Palestine, but being pro
Palestine is not we're not Christians in
the sense that you believe is solar um
feday. The idea that you're saved by
faith alone and in this case having
being pro Palestine erases all your
other sins. You can do whatever you want
to do now because it's the equivalent of
Jesus dying on the cross. We don't sorry
to say this is not what we believe. You
know, you will be you have to be held to
account for beliefs. You will not be
rewarded.
Okay, for compromising on your faith and
this is not just from a Sunnia. I know
you're a Shia perspective because Shia
traditionalists will have exactly the
same view. And there's a difference
here. And this is the bottom line
between pragmatism which is Islamic and
acceptable in some cases and compromise
which shows weakness. And I think
unfortunately with these matters, it
shows the oppos the latter. And we can't
support that aspect of things. However,
we do see that this is the lesser of two
evils. Yeah. And we understand that this
could be, you know, something inshallah
which brings the pro Palestinian cause
forward. But as for those people in the
right wing who are saying, you know,
this guy's an Islamist socialist. I
mean, just listen to yourself. Like I
think maybe it was Charlie Kirk who said
this or one of those ignores. But, you
know, these two things are incompatible
with each other. So, you know, being a
Muslim traditionist believer and at the
same time a socialist or at the same
time, you know, LGBT or engaging in
believing the morality of homosexual
acts and or transgender uh reassignment
surgeries or whatever it may be, let
alone dancing and, you know, doing the
things in the in in the marches. Yeah.
And to to these guys, it seems like
anyone with, you know, a skin color or
belief or a culture alien to theirs is a
threat. Especially if they come from
anything to do with Islam or linked with
anything remotely Islamic, even if it's,
for example, Obama. Obama, they said his
name sounds like Osama. His father
apparently is a Muslim, therefore he's a
Muslim as well. Look over here. What? So
for them that's a that's a big problem.
But Obama we knew in his pre presidency
he bombed at least about six at least
six Muslim majority countries. So same
with Sadi Khan like Sadi Khan he's come
he's promoting LGBT and this and that
and the thing is that look we can say
what this in this regard they they are
good what they're doing it's good. Which
part of it? Um the LGBT. Yeah.
[Laughter]
in the pro palestine in the pro
palestine thing we can commend them for
that we can say look well done for this
it does take a lot of guts and you know
he has been getting death threats and
the likes and it's helped him get
elected let's be honest as well so it's
prop palestine is not just something
which you have benefited it's something
which benefited you but then again also
he you know anybody doing this will be
bombarded completely utterly and the
death threats he's received the fact
that he was crying on camera we
obviously sympathize for that. We don't
want that to happen to anybody. But
somebody that is linked to Islam, that's
linked to the Islamic community, then
they should be measured by that yard
stick as well where they are not meeting
the mark just like you do with any other
politician. The same should be done over
here. And just because we're doing hosan
and we're saying look this is the you
know lesser of two evils. It doesn't
mean that's it then you just accept him
wholly and completely. You can kind of
you know you can't accept him who holy
and complete because look here's the
question right if the prophet Muhammad
sallallam was alive today this is a
question we should always be asking
ourselves let's be honest for a second
yeah despite you know that you got the
pragmatic scholars on the one hand and
the pragmatic students of knowledge and
then you've got like the ultra strict if
the prophet Muhammad wasallam was alive
today and he he knew everything that we
know about this man would he not
reprimand correct clarify I believe that
if you say that he wouldn't then you are
falling into this belief because we're
in we're in a generation of don't judge
me you don't know what's in their heart
and brother who are you the Quran
mentions
they wish that you could this is Allah
speaking to the prophet about the pagan
Arabs at the time they wish that they
you could compromise with them so that
they would compromise with you okay the
prophet wasam is you we know this hadith
famous hadith you know they told him to
stop preaching. And he said that if I
had the sun on my left hand or the the
the moon in my left hand, the right the
sun in my right hand, I would not give
this up. You know, there's nothing that
I can be tempted by. So you you will not
be commended by the Muslim. You cannot
be commended. In fact, you should be
criticized and scrutinized by the Muslim
community for compromising on such
issues. But at the same time, we know
that there's a bigger enemy. And so this
is the measured and balanced approach to
this matter and I think you will agree
with usalamlaykum.
Hey you are you wasting your time on
social media again? Your brothers and
sisters in Islam net from Norway are
establishing a masid a da center
establishing a masid to convey the
message of Islam is one of the best
deeds a Muslim can do. There's a huge
need for it in Norway. You know this and
I know this. So that makes the reward
even greater. So give generously and
Allahel will give you even more.